where better to judge the success of the
glasgow summit than the bahamas
because beyond the picture postcard
image this is a low-lying storm-battered
island nation on the brink
how are you welcome back from glasgow
yes and its prime minister's assessment
of the world leaders cop commitments is
hardly glowing i invited them to be
brave
to be courageous
and act
because as you said it's a lot of fancy
words they don't seem to have any
teeth to them
it's aspirational
they if at the end of this summit this
code red summit they're talking only
about aspirations so is that success or
failure let me put it this way i don't
like i don't want to say success or
failure what i want to say is
um progress
has been stagnant
progress is stagnant and and i hope that
we'll get out of this
quagmire
the bahamas contribution to global
greenhouse gas emissions is just 0.01
and yet this is where the impact of
warming global temperatures is
existential 80 of the land here is 3
feet or less above sea level
[Applause]
and they say the weather is ever more
extreme hurricane dorian in 2019 was one
of the most powerful ever recorded it's
worrying for me because
um our islands are being swallowed right
now by
by rising
uh sea levels
and it has to stop if you're lucky
um we may become refugees
if you are not lucky
you'll be swallowed up with the
rising sea levels
or wiped away by more and more intense
storms
among the prime minister's fears is the
non-binding nature of pledges that are
not promises which could be scrapped as
fast as governments change i think
political change
has been an enemy to success
and we need to find a way and a
mechanism
this message i left
when i left mechanism to ensure
that
that political change
will not no longer [ __ ] any progress
it sounds like you're worried that any
progress that has been made could be
undone quite quickly yes
because at the end it is the attitude of
leaders
and he had a word too on language prime
minister johnson's repeated football
analogy on humanity's struggle with
climate change is this appropriate
we all have a means of messaging
and conveying
our feelings to the general public
that's the way he's adopted to do it i
may not choose that way because for me
um enough is enough
we are this is serious business
and i think in our effort to convey the
seriousness of the times
and the consequences
that could could that could
could befall us all
needs serious language
this is where the conclusions in glasgow
matter now the alternative they say is
that our children will tell theirs there
was once a place called the bahamas
mark stone sky news in nassau